a final prayer and farewell to the late
Tamir and his half brother she no Al
Ahmed Al saah the new Amir of Kuwait
shik mishal Al Ahmed alabah is said to
take an oath at a special session of the
National Assembly but before that his
duty was to lay the late air to rest
Sheik Michelle shed a tear for his
brother shik Michelle had already been
de facto leader since 20121 when alen
shik NOA handed over his duties he was
Deputy Chief of the National Guard and
Head of State security for over a decade
but it was when he was named Crown
Prince at the age of 80 in 2020 that
thrust him into the political Limelight
I Believe by witnessing what His
Highness was able to accomplish in the
last two years plus what is known about
his character and his leadership at the
National Guard he's a reformist he is
somebody who doesn't allow nepotism or
favism to impact his decisions the
nation continues to mourn and remember
shik noaf but there are high hopes that
the new 83-year-old Amir will continue
to build on his work over the last 2
years we will see a lot of changes in
policies as well as uh improve of the
economy to compete with our neighbors
and GCC countries that what all Kuwai is
expect from
sh Kuwait is unique in the region it has
an elected Parliament a government of
appointed by the Amir but a principle of
ruling by consensus the selection of the
Crown Prince must be put before
Parliament to be voted on and must
receive a 2/3 majority over the last few
days Sheik Michelle has been receiving
dignatories it's a role he has been
doing for two years as a Crown Prince
but now he can make it his
own Kuwait did not take part in the
blockade of Qatar imposed by Saudi
Arabia Egypt the UAE and Bahrain and it
was instrumental in brokering a deal
that ended the blockade in 2021 one I
think uh the policy of Kuwait foreign
policies will remain as it is zero
enemies a lot of friends uh whether it's
regional or International Flags continue
to fly at half staff in the capital but
the Winds of Change may not come with
this Amir but when his successor is
announced with hopes it will be someone
that can take the Next Generation
forward people here in Kuwait appreciate
the country's domestic and Regional
stability and continuity and with the
transition of power to the new Amir
those are the two things they don't want
to compromise on Assad bag Al jazer
Kuwait
City make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer